welcome back to CBS morning's the man
accused of killing four University of
Idaho students is due in a Pennsylvania
courtroom this afternoon Brian coburger
is expected to waive his extradition
rights and he could be brought to Idaho
within 72 hours to face charges Dania
Backus is in Moscow Idaho Dania good
morning
good morning Adriana this afternoon's
hearing while expected to be brief could
expedite his appearance in an Idaho
courtroom a public defender for Brian
coburger a PhD criminology student at
Washington State University says his
client is calm very intelligent and
fairly shocked by his arrest once
coburger arrives in Idaho he is expected
to face four counts of first-degree
murder and one count of felony burglary
in the November 13th deaths of the
University of Idaho students the 28 year
old was taken into custody on Friday at
his parents home in eastern Pennsylvania
co-berger lives in Washington state just
15 minutes from the crime scene
investigators say they believe he broke
into the home with the intent to commit
murder now there's still no word on a
motive or whether co-burger knew the
victims it is expected more details will
be released once coburger arrives in
Idaho and is officially charged and a
probable cause affidavit is unsealed
Vlad
Diane thank you very much